we can find a balance between emotion  and logic i do believe that there are  times where we have too much logic and  too much emotion right  ah what japanese would you think that  was too much emotion or too much logic i  think it was me telling you to shut the  [ __ ] up because you don't know how to  sometimes  but anyway  i said what i said all right no i hate  you i had you i had you to go hand in  hand in times like this when there's too  much emotion involved people can  genuinely get hurt  and when it comes to logic i feel like  logic most of the time you can't go  wrong but sometimes when we're too  logical it can really disregard a group  of people or whatever it may be you know  yeah but that's but that's one of the  problems i'm talking about we're not  talking about disregarding people